[Music]
sus ins and temperatures have been at
war for centuries
the assassins believe that above all
else mankind should have free will the
tempers are more interested in power and
a way to control the human race rule of
bloodlines with the assassins guide I'm
bar one his name is Callum Lynch what do
you want from me your past
assassins are making sure that freedom
is still protected and cherished tempers
want us all dead
in your hands now
the door sort of the line we are
assassins
the concept of assassins and Templars
battling through the centuries is a
fantastic cinematic experience its
original and inventive
you hear to say to myself I understand
it's your birthday
yeah the party's just getting started
his name is Colin Minj
we've traced his bloodline back 500
years to the Assassin's Creed cow has
anyone in the world knows or cares you
no longer exist
[Music]
this place
this is your second chance
[Music]
what do you want from me your past
you're about to enter the Animus what
you see hear and feel are the memories
of your ancestor he's been dead for 500
years wait a minute
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
what I saw it there and family
[Music]
it was
you're watching you waiting to see who
you are
I believe you are destined for great
things that's fine now
we work in the dark turn up the lights
we are assassins
I'm beginning to like this
Altus understandable Michael in the
movie Michael Fassbender's character is
trapped and he has to job the leap of
faith jumping 125 feet